tonight inshaallah we wish to discuss
some of the virtues of the day of
jumu'
and a very important issue regarding the
day of jummah and that is that
there is an hour an hour meaning a time
a portion of time in which
all dua that is made sincerely and
properly to allah
with his conditions of course will be
accepted by allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and
answered during this this
period of time and that period of time
is on the day of jumu' what period of
time that is
is a difference of opinion amongst the
scholars of islam
and this is what ibm rahimahullah will
deal with and research
with us tonight
he says
that this chapter is regarding the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's traditions and ways on
the day of jumu'
and this chapter will also deal with
some of the khasas
some of the particular things particular
virtues
particular aspects that are specific to
the day of jummah
he says
[Silence]
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
was
said allah had concealed the virtue
of the day of jumu' of the day of
friday
upon those nations which have preceded
us
of jews and christians he says
allah appointed for the jews the day
of a sabbath the day of saturday
and he appointed for the christians the
people of isa
it's not what's meant by christian here
is the followers of isaac
the true followers of asa the true
followers of
he appointed for them as their special
day of the week
as the day of sunday
and allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala then
created this ummah
and brought it forth and appointed for
this
ummah the day of jumu' the day of
friday
what does this mean what this means is
that
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has given
particular virtue
to particular days and
the most amount of virtue
and the most amount of potential
reward is found on the day of jumu'
but allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala did not
appoint the day of jumu'
as the special day of worship for the
people of musa he appointed for them the
day of saturday which is
less in its virtue likewise the people
of
isa alayhis he appointed for them the
day of
sunday al ahad
and that is of lesser
virtue than the day of jumu'
and he appointed for this ummah the
ummah of muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the day which has in it
the most possible potential virtue
of all of the days of the week this is
the virtue of allah
which he distributes upon his creation
as he sees fit and as he chooses
and so it doesn't mean that the day of
saturday was not
virtuous for the people of musa it was
virtuous likewise that the day of sunday
was not virtuous for the people of
isa is virtuous for them
but the amount of potential virtue
that is in the day of jumu' is not in
the other days
and so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
reserved this
highest amount of potential virtue
for this ummah which would be on the day
of jumu'
and this is part of the honor that allah
has given this ummah aside from other
nations
we have to understand something and that
is that
this nation has
opportunities and has
a relief that was not allotted to
any other nation before
just as we have aspects of revelation
that were not allotted to
nations before what does this mean
in order to understand this we have to
understand first of all the difference
between
giving virtue and taking away
from a people and punishing them
in sahih al-bukhari the prophet
salallahu
this nation his nation
when we say this ummah
this nation or the nation of the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
what is meant by it is anyone who is
born
after the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
was appointed as a messenger
or anyone who was
you know who was conscious who was able
to
benefit from the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's
from his message and from his revelation
until the end of time so
we have the ummah of the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
alaihi wasallam is anyone whom
his message applies to
anyone whom his message applies to
they are considered his
and so he is the final of prophets
the final of messengers his book is the
final of books
and his ummah his nation is the last of
the nations of mankind after this nation
there will be the day of resurrection
the day of judgment
there is no other nations or prophets or
messengers or divine revelations
after the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam and so
the prophet alaihi wasallam gave an
example of this he said
the example or the parable or the
similitude
of this ummah this nation
to the nations that have preceded it
meaning the jews the christians the
nations of the various prophets and
messengers that have preceded this
nation
is a man or an individual who
hired some workers to do some work for
him
so here in this parable
the one who is hiring or the one who is
giving the
reward and giving the employment
this is as allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has chosen these nations and given them
the various books
because allah
i am going he said to the angels i am
going to
appoint in the earth a
successor meaning to succeed allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala in the earth and
implement his will thereon
and so allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
has created the various nations
and he chose of them whom he chose
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said this nation
to the nations that have preceded it is
like
an individual who hired a group of
people
to work for him and to do some
particular work
on a contract and so these individuals
they worked
until the middle of the day
and they were no longer able to work
and so allah subhanahu wa he gave them
their
their pay and then
from the middle of the day until evening
he hired another group of people
and then they were unable to finish the
work and complete it
and he gave them the pay that he
promised them
then he brought another group of people
and he employed them to finish the work
between early evening until sunset until
dusk
and he promised them more reward and
more pay than those who preceded them
and so they took this job and they
completed it
and so the other workers that came
before
they worked longer hours and they had
a subjectively more difficult task
and so they complained to the
individual who hired them
and said we worked more than them but
you
paid us less and so the
this person asked them hel
have i not given you
what you earned they said yes
you you paid us what is fair and you
paid us
what we worked for you didn't
you didn't decrease or take away from
are worth anything but you did pay them
more he said
he said and as for the extra pay that i
have given to those who completed the
work
that is it's my money it's my
property and i can give it to whom i
choose
and so the nations that came before
the nation of musa alaihi
the jews the nation of the christians
the
the the people of isa alaihissalam
these are the different groups they came
before us
they did a certain amount of work and
they were given a virtue
they were given reward for that work
however allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala chose
this nation
from amongst the rest of the nations and
gave particular
precedence and virtue to them and so
this nation
is relieved of a lot of the hardships
that previous nations went through yet
they are given
more revelation a more virtuous prophet
a more virtuous book less strict and
stringent regulations
and there is no difficulty in the
religion of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
upon this ummah
and he gave them more reward
now a person can't say well that's not
fair it is fair
because allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did
not oppress anyone
and he gave everyone his due
however he chose to give an additional
portion
to the last and the most latter of those
nations which is this nation
alhamdulillah and so
we have been given a messenger that is
the most virtuous of all messengers
and we have been given the best of role
models
that messenger was appointed the best
and most virtuous
of companions and the best and most
virtuous of
apostles and
and the best and most virtuous
of followers the companions
and disciples and so they are the most
virtuous of mankind after the prophets
and messengers
holistically speaking
and so the disciples of our prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam are
the most virtuous of the disciples of
any
prophet or messenger likewise
he has given this prophet the
best and most virtuous of
revelations the quran it is the most
concise
yet it is all-encompassing and
all-inclusive of
everything relevant from the nations
that have preceded us
and the revelations that have come
before it
and so this quran has everything
relevant
from revelation that has preceded it and
it has
also additional things and additional
information
that is not found in the other
revelations
that have been given to the prophets and
messengers and so for instance
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
mentions that
that
is particular to this ummah
and also the final closing verses of
surat al-baqarah
they are particular to this prophet and
this messenger
no other prophet has been given
that though that
that aspect of revelation
likewise from the quran
which starts from surat kaff or surat
al-hajir
all the way to surat and nas those
chapters and verses and revelations
they are specific to the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
no other prophet has been given that
that virtuous
revelation as he likewise the miracles
that were performed by and through the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam many of them were
very particular to him he has particular
laws particular allowances that were not
allotted to the nations that preceded
our nation and so this is
the virtue of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
it is the dominion of allah and he
choose he does with it what he chooses
and so just as
the human being allah has created all
of the humans and he has chosen the
prophets from amongst those humans
can we now say well that's not fair why
weren't we chosen as prophets
we were given our opportunity and we
were endowed with the blessings that
allah subhanahu has endowed us with
but he gave an additional portion to the
prophets and messengers
he did not wrong us but he did give
additional
virtue to them and so
this is to the discretion of allah
subhanahu wa
for this reason allah subhanahu
he says and your lord he is the sole
creator and he is the soul one who
chooses to give virtue to any of that
creation
over any other portion of that creation
so just as allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
the only one who has created
likewise he is the only one who has the
discretion
to give additional virtue to any of that
creation subhana
now this doesn't mean that it is just
willy-nilly or
random that's not to be understood
rather allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chooses
of his creation that which is
that which is in line with his wisdom
and his knowledge subhanahu ta'ala
and his mercy and his virtue but
ultimately it boils down to the
discretion of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala likewise
is the days of the week and so the
nations that have preceded us
they have been given virtuous days but
those days are not as virtuous as the
day of jumu'
the day of jumaa is the most virtuous
day and so he reserved
that day for us the nation of the
prophet muhammed
he says that the day of jumu'
was not given to those
nations that have preceded us for the
jews the followers of muslim for them he
appointed the day of saturday
for the nasara
appointed for them the day of sunday and
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala created
this ummah this final nation of the
prophet muhammad
and he appointed for their special
weekly
holiday and observance the day of friday
and he had made these three days as the
most
virtuous of the days of the week friday
saturday and sunday
and likewise this is symbolic
this is symbolic and emblemic of
all that is to follow of the nations he
says
they are those who will follow
us on the day of resurrection we were
the ones who followed them in existence
meaning we are the last of nations but
we will be the first
of nations on the day of resurrection
and allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala will
reward
and he will bring forth and
deal
with judgment etc this nation first
so this nation will be the first nation
to enter paradise
it will be the first nation to be judged
all other
nations will be judged after and
based on the judgment of this nation
all other nations will be judged
based on the intercession of the
prophet muhammad
no one will enter paradise before the
prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam as the narrations
mentioned
let's take a stop here and discuss
some of the issues that plague us with
regards to language
so many many
years ago centuries ago during the dark
ages
european dark ages there was a huge
divide between christianity and paganism
and as
the church during those times and it
still is today
was very powerful and
it was important for anyone who was a
king
or ruler that he incorporate
the power of the church into his own
power to consolidate power
he had to control the church
and this is what happened
however there was a large portion
of the population that were pagans
idol worshipers idolaters
polytheists and so
for political gain many of these
polytheists and pagans
were incorporated into the christian
world
and they were incorporated into the
christian world
by force so any
people that would be brought into the
christian empire if they were pagans or
idolaters
they would be forced to enter into
christianity
however the emperors and the kings at
that time they understood that
this is easier said than done and so
what did they do
they changed all of the times and days
and holidays to coincide with
the days and holidays of the pagans
so that everybody would be celebrating
on the same day
the pagans could claim that they were
christian
but really they were celebrating their
own celebrations
the christians could celebrate on
their own days as well
and claim that they were christian and
everybody could be happy
and this way we could consolidate power
political power
and so lots of things
were changed
of those things was the day of christmas
christ's mass which is supposed to be
the day
of the birth of isallam
and this just happened to be
to coincide with the
winter solstice and equinox
so it happened to be december 23rd 24th
25th
and the day of
the birth of isa alaihissalam
was changed to the descent the 25th
of december this does not coincide with
the bible at all
the bible actually mentions that
shepherds and
you know we all learn this in school
that the little little drummer boy and
the three kings who saw the north star
and the the shepherd
that came well there's not any shepherds
out during the dead of winter
running around with their flock in the
snow to graze
everything's dead this happens in the
spring
this is when isa alaihissalam was most
likely born and that's what's
found in the quran as well right
that it was when the dates were
ripe and mariam alaihissalam was given
of these dates
during this time it wasn't the dead of
winter and december 25th however this is
a very
this is a very important
day for
the pagan world and for idolaters
because this marks the
winter solstice this is when a very
important time comes in for the end of
year
and the change of seasons likewise
easter
right if we look at easter it happens to
coincide with
as well the spring
solstice when the
time and the seasons are changing and
shifting
and this is the day that was allegedly
the resurrection
of isa alaihissalam which
this this was changed to be the day
of easter easter sunday
why in order to consolidate that power
but if we look at when it was alleged
that jesus was crucified
well people say it was good friday
but it could not have been good friday
it would had to have been good wednesday
because it was supposed to be three days
and three nights
as is alleged in the bible that just as
jonah was in the belly of the whale
for three days and three nights so will
he be
and he says the son of man be in the
belly
or in the tomb for three days and three
nights
so if good friday was the day he was
crucified which you know obviously this
is hypothetical
we know that it couldn't have been
any time before sunset
on friday because that's saturday it had
to be three days and three nights
if this took place on friday then
why is it that sunday is the day that he
is allegedly
resurrected right that doesn't make
sense
also we see very strange symbols
for these holidays such as burning logs
in the fire on christmas and a tree an
evergreen tree that is decorated
and we see santa claus right he goes
around through the earth and
gives out presents to children
and reindeer right none of these things
are middle eastern none of these things
have anything to do with
religion or christianity right
this is something which our traditions
of mesopotamian idolaters
and pagans that was incorporated into
christianity
just as the time was so were the rituals
likewise in easter we have bunnies and
rabbits what does this have to do with
the resurrection of isa alaihissalam it
has nothing to do with the resurrection
of jesus christ
that of course we are speaking
hypothetical as muslims we
know that there was no resurrection
there was no crucifixion for that matter
but it's it's curious that there are
eggs and there are rabbits well rabbits
don't lay eggs
because we have eggs and we have rabbits
what do these things have to do with
easter
they have nothing to do with easter even
the name itself
easter what is that this is
a reference to the goddess of fertility
and mesopotamian paganism likewise the
rabbit
is considered to be a
a symbol of fertility because rabbits
are very
quick to reproduce right and they have
numerous amounts of litters throughout
the year
likewise the eggs we have eggs that have
been discovered
painted ostrich eggs
from africa dating back as far as 5000
years long before
isa alaihissalam ever walked the
earth
so these are ancient pagan rituals that
are performed
and the timings of these rituals are
also to coincide
with pagan rituals in order to
consolidate power at the time
if you understand this you will begin to
understand a lot of the things that we
see
that we've just been born with and we
see around us and we take for granted
but nobody really sits and thinks what
does this have to do with
christianity or what does this have to
do with
isabel likewise is the days of the week
the days of the week we have monday
right
which comes from mono which is one the
first day
then we have tuesday
wednesday which is a reference to
a wedding which is to get married on
wednesday why because it's considered to
be
the most virtuous time and day of the
week to be married
right then we have thursday which is
thor's day the day of thor then we have
friday and saturday which is a reference
to saturn
which is the god of
allegedly the god of of
farming right
the god that has to do with
bringing forth harvest and so forth
and then we have sunday which is the day
of
for the worship of the sun god
likewise our gregorian
calendar is based on that as well
right in the days of the week
this is why it's important for us to
learn as muslims that we have our own
calendar
that is is completely void of any
shirk
or any poly polytheism or paganism or
idolatry
right so the language of
english and the days of the week and
the day months of the year
the calendar and the holidays all of
this revolves around paganism
if you trace it back i mean we use these
things because we have to
in the time and place that we live but
we have
our own religious calendar we have our
own religious days of the week so we
have al ahad
which is sunday which is the first day
of the week in islamic calendar
we have al-ithnan which is the second
day
which is the third day which is the
fourth day
which is the fifth day and then we have
jumma which is the day of gathering and
mustering in congregation
right which is articulates our religious
rights on the day of friday
and we have also a sabbath a sabbath is
taken from
the root word a sabbath
the day of sabbath is the day when there
was no
when there was no work it was the
sabbath for
the people who have come before us and
so we see that these days of the week
have no shirk in them
they have no references or homages to
any false gods or pagans likewise the
months of the year
as well they are
particular to this ummah and they have
and they are
void of any references to paganism or
idolatry and unfortunately
you know we do have to use
gregorian calendars
in where we live i mean that's as a
matter of fact most of the world is
is based on that now but it doesn't mean
that we should be ignorant of our own
calendar
many muslims i won't say most but many
do not know the
months of the muslim calendar they
couldn't if you say
list them to me 12 months we could not
list them
list the sacred ones we could not list
them most people think that ramadan is
the most sacred month and it is not
right likewise
the a person's age
most people that you speak to muslims
they do not know their
age their islamic age and that is the
age and that is the calendar that all
that all religious rights are based upon
so for example
if a person reaches the age of 7
or reaches the age of 15
or reaches the age of 40 these are
significant milestones
in a muslim's life this is based on the
islamic lunar calendar
not based on the gregarian
calendar
solar calendar this is a very important
issue
many people don't know their own age or
their birth date
on in the islamic lunar calendar
and this is a shame this is unfortunate
that even muslims or
muslim leaders or imams etc are ignorant
of this issue
what is your what when were you born on
the islamic calendar we don't know
how old are you i'm not sure what are
the
months of the year we don't know and
this is part of the
part of the
psychological colonization that has
taken place
on the psyche of the muslims at large
just caused us to become detached from
our religion
detached from our calendar detach from
our
language detach from our books detach
from our scholars
and now we don't even know the
difference this is the whole idea
so it's important for us to understand
that
for example if a person is to fast for
two consecutive months
those are two consecutive lunar months
not gregarian ones
if a person is to look at his date
of birth it is to be in islamic
date of birth and so there will be a
difference
i mean a person will be one or two years
older than they would be in gregarian
calendar months because of the
discrepancy in the number of days that
are counted for each
year so these are important things for
us to know these are important things
for us to teach our children
and to pass on these things because
fortunately
alhamdulillah our
customs and our language in the arabic
language
is a language that has been scrubbed and
purified
from paganism it has been scrubbed
and purified from idolatry that plagues
languages such as the english language
everything from the day of
the day of the week until to the
the counting system the numbers the
months of the year the holidays
everything is based on
idolatry of ancient times which is
keeping alive
many old mesopotamian pagan cultures
which
otherwise would have been dead by now
and there are many things that we see
around us that we
do not investigate for example
certain companies use certain brand
names
and certain symbols which
are not permissible for a muslim to wear
and to dawn
a good example of that is nike nike is
actually
referred to by italians as nikki this is
the way that it should be
said and nikki is the
is the goddess of victory
that they would worship prior to battle
and the swoosh mark the check mark is
actually
one of her wings that would be depicted
over victorious armies and victorious
leagues
in ancient greek mythology
this is not permissible for a muslim to
wear these things
we see these symbols we just put them on
our body we plaster
these things on our bodies and then we
come and pray
no different than putting a big cross on
your back or on your shirt
or on your hat or putting the star of
david
on what is alleged
to be the star of david or any other
marking that is particular to
a pagan or non-muslim religion and
then come into saleh or come into the
masjid et cetera
or even not soledad just having it on
your body is something which is
impermissible
according to the consensus of the
muslims scholars and so
we have to make sure that we understand
that
the language we speak which is english
and the days of the week and the months
and
a lot of our language and even our
customs are based on ancient pagan
rituals such as knocking on wood
say well i haven't ever broken my leg
knock on wood right this is a type of
shirk
which is a homage to one of the gods of
ancient paganism
this is something that is it is
impermissible for a muslim to say such a
thing
even if it's just for laughs even if
it's just a joke
the thing the thankful thing that we
have
is that as muslims and if our religion
is and and as muslims our
language that is deeply entwined with
our religion is the arabic language
and so it has been purified
by the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and his companions from any
references to shirk or paganism
that was the custom of the people of
that time
and alhamdulillah in largely
the arabic language is a pure
of these types of references and
parables of
that have to do with the worship of
idols even though there was a
a long time and spout of arabs that had
worshipped idols but it had not made its
way into the language
too far and it was reversed
and then the arabic language the best of
it was preserved by the quran
and preserved by the muslims this is why
the arabic language
is so important because
what language you think in and speak in
will determine
how your mind works this is an issue
which we will need to discuss
in further detail later in our
discussion on the day of jumu'
that is enough for tonight inshaallah
will continue on next week
thank you very much for joining us we
ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he teach us of wisdom what we are
ignorant of remind us of it
what we have been made to forget and
that he benefit us with whatever he
teaches us
to